bonsoir vous tous je vais continuer dans
cette cette entreprise de
désapprentissage pour réfléchir à la
notion de comment est ce qu'on peut
apprendre à désapprendre à cacher notre
différence car c'est assez surprenant en
ce moment il ya beaucoup de perse
d'autres on va commencer par des
entreprises beaucoup d'entreprises qui
sont à fond sur innovation faucon qu'on
innove en management en offre en process
quoi qu'il en soit il faut qu'on
continue même au niveau personnel on est
en train de parler de personal branding
ouais il faut qu'on devienne un petit
peu différent qu'on se démarque de la
concurrence
pour trouver un boulot rapidement et
puis donner envie à des clients surtout
pour ceux qui sont indépendants de nous
acheter entre guillemets pourtant en
france c'est surprenant parce qu'autant
on recherche l'originalité autant la
différence continue à faire peur à être
un petit peu honteuse donc géré on peut
réfléchir à ça et vous aider pour faire
trois choses la première je vais vous
parler de mon expérience parce que c'est
elle on doit parler de soi c'est pas ma
partie préférée je vous reconnaitre
ensuite on va parler des neurosciences
parce que si vous parlez pas de
neurosciences dans un tête vous avez un
peu quand même raté votre vie et ensuite
essayer de vous donner des choses à
emmener chez vous pour voir si on peut
ensemble remplir cette dernière page du
fameux livret que vous avez entre les
mains alors moi je m'appelle benjamin
j'ai 40 ans et depuis un moment
maintenant bientôt quarante mois
et je suis en fait un produit un peu
défectueux d'une éducation à la chaîne
qui a été basée sur des valeurs de
conformité et de standardisation c'est à
dire que en gros je me suis aperçu que
j'ai perdu pas mal de temps de vie on va
dire entre 5 et 10 ans a essayé de me
conformer à un système qui n'était pas
le mien
la première chose ça a été le
copier-coller l'apprentissage
mala ou copier des enfin il fallait
vraiment apprendre à copier en écoutant
nos professeurs et répété sagement ce
qu'ils étaient sachant que la tension je
n'ai rien contre l'éducation
d'indications nationale au contraire
vous allez voir après en fait moi
j'avais juste un petit souci c'est que
depuis tout petit je suis hyper actif
alors pas turbulences assez facile nous
turbulent mais vraiment hyper actif donc
ça veut dire en gros que le détail
m'ennuie pour être poli donc quand on
m'a forcé à apprendre des choses parker
genre des poésies ligne par ligne je me
suis aperçu au bout de trois ans qu'en
fait il fallait que j'apprenne comme ça
parce que j'avais besoin de voir toute
la page et pourrait pour être capable en
refermant la les yeux d'être capable
d'identifier où étaient les informations
sur la page ma mère un jour m'a appris
m'a pris en train de faire ça elle m'a
envoyé chez l'oculiste donc ce n'était
pas l'objectif l'autre chose c'est que
je m'ennuie très facilement donc ça à
mes amis le savent en gros vous avez
deux minutes pour me parler vous avez
intérêt à être concis est intéressant
sinon hein je décroche de jeu commence à
faire est en mode automatique installé
comme les chiens de l'âge arrière soit
je suis parti ce qui fait que avec cette
c2 ces deux petits soucis dans le global
est plutôt de m'ennuyer rapidement je
suis incapable de refaire deux fois la
même chose même face à un problème que
j'ai déjà rencontré il faudra que je
trouve un autre face une autre façon que
je penserais même pas automatiquement à
la façon dont j'ai résolu ce problème
que je vois de nouveau donc on dit
toujours il faut apprendre de ses
erreurs
ben moi je peux vous dire qu'avec ce
système là je fais des erreurs plutôt
cinq ou six fois juste pour être sûr que
ça marche pas
donc voilà alors les entreprises aiment
bien ça parce qu'avec en faisant cette
approche on change un peu les choses la
seconde chose que j'ai appris c'était
qu'il fallait se conformer au groupe et
limin c'était une question de vie ou de
mort je m'explique j'ai vite compris
lorsque je suis arrivé à l'école que
avoir de bonnes notes c'était pas top
pour se faire des amis valait mieux
avoir la bonne note qui va bien c'est à
dire pas trop hein pour être dans le
groupe g a pris également qu'il fallait
mieux avoir la main la bonne marque de
chaussures à l'époque donc c'est dans
les années 90 c'était peut être pas mal
d'avoir d'avoir des adidas ou alors un
survêtement sergio tacchini ça c'était
la grande place
également j'ai appris que il valait
mieux également faire le bon sport est
passionné par les bons par les bons les
bonnes passion donc à l'époque c'était
le foot donc je sais pas si dans la
salle il ya des pans ce qui est des
jeunes garçons avec beaucoup
d'expérience maintenant qu'ils se
rappellent la honte d'être choisi en
dernier pour l'équipe de foot donc ça
c'était moi tout le temps donc il a
fallu je trouve d'autres d'autres moyens
en plus
donc c'est vraiment l'idée c'est que on
a commencé un peu à me j'ai appris ce
que c'était que le bowling mais il genre
il ya dix ans alors que je les ai vécus
en vrai ou parce que je refusais quand
même de me conformer à groupe et donc je
risquais un peu parfois ma vie entre
guillemets à la récré mais au delà de
risquer ma vie je régale je risquais
également quand je rentrais chez moi le
xiii de mes parents qui eux m'ont donné
une peur de l'avenir j'espère que tu
travaille bien à l'école parce que c'est
en travaillant bien l'école quand on a
un boulot dans une grande boîte ouais
bon c'était des années 80 et chose
d'être un petit peu simple comme ça et
j'espère que dans l'école également tu
te concentres sur les maths parce
qu'avec les maths tu pourras faire ce
que tu veux pilote d'avion astronautes
ne renonce à exister pas chirurgien
voilà ça par contre ça n'a pas bougé en
réalité moi je l'avais un kiff personnel
j'avais une passion personnelle que j'ai
depuis que j'ai dix ans j'avais
découvert un musée de train à vapeur qui
est bizarrement pas très loin d'ici
depuis j'ai dix ans le métier je
voudrais conduire des trains à vapeur et
qu'on me foute la paix aussi moi je veux
conduire des trains je veux que ce soit
mon métier non mes parents m'expliquer
c'est pas possible c'est pas un métier
et puis en plus comme une durée de vie
une espérance de vie et un conducteur de
train qui doit être à peu près égale à
celle d'un cycliste professionnel avec
le charbon toi c'est pas top
sauf qu'il ya quelque chose qui est
assez original c'est que mes 18 ans un
parc d'attractions américains est venue
s'installer pas très loin de chez moi
dirigé par une grosse souris en fait ce
parc
recrutait des conducteurs de train
donc j'ai envoyé mon cv parce que ça
tombe bien ça fait cinq ans que j'en
lisais des trains
et donc bizarrement j'ai été recruté et
je me suis retrouvé en même temps
j'étais ans dans une école de commerce
parce que comme beaucoup de gens
de mon âge à l'époque je n'avais pas
quoi faire de ma vie donc le commerce et
les parents ont les moyens c'est quand
même pas mal c'est à laisser encore
trois quatre ans pour se faire une idée
je me suis retrouvé à me rendre compte
que 1 je bossais en étant déguisé deux
que je conduisais des trains et en plus
ce qui s'est passé en tout cas c'est
marrant c'est que un jour je sors maman
parce que j'avais déjà cette montre pour
regarder l'heure et là il y avait un des
grands chefs des grands comptes
américains qui me voient qu'ils disent
est incroyable c'est en caractères c'est
absolument génial tu es vraiment engagés
impliqué dans ton travail donc je vais
te mettre dans le dans le fast track qui
va te permettre de devenir manager de
l'équipe en fait moi je regardais
jusqu'alors pour rentrer chez moi mais
où
est donc je me suis retrouvé le chef
j'avais 21 ans j'étais encore en école
de commerce et j'avais 70-70 bonhomme la
plupart plus âgés que moi de 20
nationalités donc ça va en tout cas
donné une petite chose une explication
que ben finalement rien n'est prévu on
peut pas prévoir ce qu'on va faire ça
sert à rien de faire des grands plans de
diplômes de parcours toute façon la vie
s'occupe toujours de vous de vous
surprendre et c'est pas plus mal
troisième chose que j'ai apprise
c'est que appris c'est que
en gros il valait mieux avoir sa
différence sa passion en dehors du
travail qui valait mieux séparer le pro
avec le perso or ce qui s'est passé pour
moi c'est que quelques années après
avoir été diplômé je suis parti en
australie donc ça c'est le running gag
depuis tout à l'heure aussi benoît slim
si tu nous entends sauf que mais je n'ai
pas vécu la même expérience parce que
j'y suis resté huit ans
et en fait on arrivant là bas je suis
arrivé dans un pays où un ciné en
particulier où il faut savoir que 60 %
des habitants de sydney ne sont pas nés
en australie - il ya les indiens des
africains du sud des américains je vous
en passe en fait c'était vraiment un
petit microcosme du monde dans une ville
est en fait chaque personne que je
rencontrais
ben partager l'univers montrer leur
différence alors devrait forcément dès
qu'on a un sari tout de suite on voit
comment on est différent mais surtout
être capable de mettre des mots pour
vous passionnez dans ce qu'il faisait et
également été curieux de connaître quel
était votre univers à vous donc c'est
comme ça que je me suis retrouvé à
m'intéresser
ce que faisait le métier de dj au
deltaplane au poker halak et pop donc la
musique coréenne tant de sujets assez
assez amusant de rencontrer des
personnes qui partageaient donc ces
trois expériences déjà mon permis j'ai
créé ma première entreprise en australie
en faisant exactement le contraire de ce
qu'on me disait toujours c'est
d'ailleurs je les fais avec un ami sans
faire aucun plan et en faisant le
contraire de ce que faisaient mes
concurrents on est passé de 0 à 50
salariés en un peu moins de deux ans le
truc qui était pas mal
là dessus je suis rentré en france
australien un petit peu désoeuvrés j'ai
commencé à bouquiner pas mal de choses
autour de tour des neurosciences et j'ai
découvert un livre alors je pourrais
vous citer 5 litres ont changé ma vie me
suis lassé le dernier en date
iconoclaste écrit par un
neuroscientifique s'appelle grégory bird
alors rapidement iconoclaste c'est pas
une insulte d'humains entre
trompe-la-mort bêcher bouzouki et ça le
salto pittet que je sais pas quoi de
capitaine haddock iconoclaste ça vient
de l'empereur léon iii qui était
empereur de byzance qui en 17 126 stade
été décidé qu'il fallait arrêter de
faire des représentations en statut de
dieu que dieu c'est immatériel dieu
c'est tout ça et mais en tout cas ils
commençaient à se trouver que les
catholiques tourner un petit peu veau
d'or en adorant des icônes ce soit des
peintures ou d où des statuts donc il a
décidé qu'il fallait détruire toute
chose qui essayaient de ressembler à
jésus-christ ou adieu donc ça a été le
premier à chercher à détruire les donc
la détruire les icônes voilà
l'iconoclaste alors fait ce n'était pas
le premier mais puisque déjà les
égyptiens avaient souvent pour habitude
de démolir les statuts des prédécesseurs
en tout cas par extension un iconoclaste
et quelqu'un qui n'a pas de respect pour
l'ancien parce que c'est anciens
je vais vous dire place aux jeunes
messei place aux jeunes c'est un peu ça
que ça veut dire c'est également
quelqu'un qui n'a pas
de qui ne se comporte pas aux croyances
aux coutumes populaires donc en langage
de 2014 ça veut dire que c'est quelqu'un
qui est sorti de la matrice est capable
de savoir qu'il est dans une matrice et
qui n'a pas d'en sortir et revenir c'est
plus compliqué mais en tout cas il
comprend qu'il est dans un système
iconoclaste selon ses c'est
neurosciences ces trois choses la
première c'est l'incapacité à refaire la
même chose face à un problème déjà
rencontré
c'est à dire qu'elles sont des personnes
qui restent imperméables à l' influence
d autres à la conformité et encore plus
à leur expérience passée ce que
malheureusement on a tous tendance à
utiliser notre expérience passée pour
faire des prérequis faire des raccourcis
sur sur notre notre futur eux ils font
pas ça je vous présente pas comme un
exemple c'est birch la liste alors
heures chavez en fait il a un lancer une
marque s'appelle burt's bées et ce mec
extraordinaire il est passé de
photographes un clochard à un apiculteur
à milliardaires à ermite
l'austère que chacune de ces expériences
a servi à rien pour la suivante
la seconde ce sont des gens qui ont
maîtrisé leurs peurs versez pas qu'ils
ont pas peur c'est qu'ils maîtrisent
leur peur en tout cas il ya une peur
qu'ils n'ont pas c'est la peur du
ridicule
vous croyez évidemment quand je mets mon
chapeau je me lit et les gens qui vont
au moins elle est un drôle d'air soit
concupiscent soit ce mec-là il a perdu
la tête soit qu'ils vont me regarder le
tête en bas comme j'en ai vu faisant
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière alors
je sais que c'est un peu bizarre le
pantalon ceara je sais que faisait
alors un exemple de personnes qui aient
quelques pour moi nos spas qui a pas
peur entre guillemets ça a été le prix
nobel 2005 qui s'appelle paris marchal
qu'un australien
de cette green et qui en fait pour
prouver que le les ulcères n'était pas
seulement dû au stress mais à une
bactérie qui s'appelle la l'hélicoptère
baxter
qui au pilori ça j'en suis sûr un
hélicoptère batère pilori en fait il
s'est injecté la bac de tirer lui-même
parce qu'on n'avait pas droit de faire
des essais en australie comme ici on n'a
pas décidé sur l'être humain
et finalement il était malade et donc il
a prouvé que les ulcères était due à une
bactérie au prix nobel de la médecine et
de la psychologie dans la foulée
satam c'est costaud
la troisième chose à quoi on peut
reconnaître un iconoclaste c'est les
trois choses 1 c'est pas l'un ou l'autre
c'est l'e3 c'est que ce sont des gens
qui sont pas des ermites ils vivent pas
dans les bois ils sont capables de
d'avoir une preuve de faire preuve d'
influence et de vous présenter leur
univers et de vous faire envie de vous
donner envie de s'intéresser à cet
univers en fait vous dit deux choses un
mathématicien c'est sexy et 2 j'aurais
peut-être dû mieux bosser à l'école en
maths tellement il est fort il est très
très très fort donc voyez ces trois
choses
décrypte ce que c'est qu'un iconoclaste
alors maintenant les neurosciences ne me
disent oh si vous êtes né iconoclaste ou
pas donc vous voulez tout ne vous l'êtes
pas alors comme je suis toujours contre
ce qu'on essaie de nous vendre qui sont
il n'y a pas le choix c'est soit ça soit
ça je pense qu'il ya un moyen pour aider
tout le monde à prendre un peu de recul
que vous soyez manager ou c'est en quête
d'emploi que vous soyez le matin on
devrait réfléchir ce que de comment vous
allez vous habiller je suis certain
qu'il ya au moins trois petites choses
qui peuvent vous et trois réflexions à
voir prendre du recul la première chose
ce serait vous posez une première
question qui est pourquoi est ce que je
fais ça
pourquoi est-ce que je concède décision
pourquoi est-ce que j'hésite entre une
chemise bleu clair et une chemise bleu
ciel entre un quotidien pas un
costume gris gris foncé et un costume
gris moyen pourquoi est ce que je
choisis est ce que c'est parce que c'est
facile parce que c'est l'usagé parce que
c'est la convention non parce que je
suis feignants voilà juste pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que je fais ça ou
peut-être aussi parce que attention
celui-là il est pas bon peut-être parce
qu'on a toujours fait comme ça pourquoi
est-ce que je challenge serait si ça a
été comme c'est comme ça depuis toujours
il ya pas raison que ça change ça c'est
on appelle ça les tours de l'innovation
en entreprise qui pensent comme ça la
deuxième chose la deuxième question donc
après le pourquoi je fais ça c'est ben
si j'essaye qu'est ce que je risque
c'est un grand malade comme barry
ça peut être ennuyeux pour ma carrière
ça va peut-être aller contre
le la notion de risque
voilà vraiment réfléchir est ce que
vraiment je risque quelque chose est ce
que je risque ma vie ce que je risque de
rater un virage dans ma carrière et la
troisième chose parce qu'on ne peut pas
être iconoclaste tout seul est ce que je
suis capable de formuler mon idée de la
partager
est-ce que vous pouvez vous quittez
peut-être un peu bizarre votre façon de
vous habiller ou je sais pas est ce que
vous pouvez la formule est est ce que
vous pouvez retrouver des gens qui vont
vous aider à grandir et à ranger 7 et à
partager cette idée en fait en faisant
ça ils risquent de se passer de choses
la première certaines personnes vont
vous trouvez excentrique qui en d'autres
mots veut dire
la deuxième parce que tous les
personnages que vous que je vous ai
présenté et tellement d'autres et je
pense que beaucoup si ce n'est pas tout
les toker les speakers vous avez vu il
sur scène et je pense pas mal d'entre
vous aussi
sont des iconoclastes
l'autre chose qui va se passer donc un
parent tu sais que je pense qu'on est
tous un peu immature
je pense que si les gens commencent à
dire de vous que vous êtes immature quel
que soit votre âge
je crois qu'on va commencer à aller dans
la bonne direction de ce que le monde a
vraiment besoin aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il a il a besoin que simplement on
une phrase qu' on apprenne à
désapprendre à être des adultes tout
simplement merci